as i said a few videos ago
ubisoft announced the expansion into
what they are calling
a division universe where they've been
working on additional ways to introduce
the division franchise
to even more gamers and this has set
them up to move on a trajectory that
will include more titles
and more transmedia content such as the
division mobile game
so i said i'd stop speculating about
what was to come with these new
division-based games but
i guess i lied i can't help myself but
this time i feel that i have a little
more to back up what i'm hoping to see
it isn't the first time that the
divisions talked about including the
mobile side of gaming
those of you have been around playing
the division for a while will remember
or have read about the companion app
that was originally planned to be
released at the same time as the
division one
this would allow mobile gamers to
interact with friends playing the main
game
the player on the app would be the one
manning a support drone
that could rain death from above or buff
the armor of teammates
or alternatively reduce the armor of
hostiles
however this was canned before release
due to the imbalance it created
the developers confirmed that it
compromised the team-based competitive
gameplay
to be fair i was never surprised by this
as much as i loved the idea behind it
i could imagine the disadvantage and
balancing issues this would have created
not to mention the number of technical
difficulties this would have included in
the long run
regardless ubisoft has been no stranger
to mobile games
in recent years they've released
spin-offs based on assassin's creed
rabbids just dance and trials
they've also featured the tom clancy
brand with tom clancy's elite squad
a crossover title that features heroes
from rainbow six
ghost recon the division splinter cell
and hawks franchises
technically api is an acronym for
application
programming interface this basically
means a software interface that allows
two applications to communicate with
each other
in gaming this allows the game and
software to interact with one another
and share rules settings specifications
and data it's only natural to think that
the mobile game or app
could simply be a way to tie all the
games together a number of you may be
aware of websites like the division
tracker
where your gaming stats over time are
rounded up showing things like total pve
kills
pvp kills time played type of enemy
killed
most used weapon types and much much
more
it would be pretty cool to mess around
with loadouts and gear too and it could
possibly even link the main game and
heartlands together somehow
while i like the idea of this type of
companion app i'm fairly certain this
isn't the direction they're going to
take
if we remember back to the only
information they've given us so far
ubisoft stated that they've been
exploring additional ways to introduce
the division to even more players
that games like heartland is to offer a
whole new experience
they are wanting to appeal to new
audiences and different games
to try and spread the name and gain a
larger portion of the industry market
share
whether you're familiar with this term
or not you've likely heard of the game
pokemon go augmented reality gaming is
the integration of game visual and audio
content with the user's environment in
real time
more often than not these games
superimpose a pre-created environment
on top of the user's actual environment
with pokemon go the game uses your
phone's gps and clock to detect where
and when you are in the game and make
the pokemon appear
around you as you move around different
and more types of pokemon will appear
depending on where you are
and what time it is this mix of a game
and real world interacting
is known as augmented reality
no i don't want to run around catching
pokemon this is probably just the most
well-known version of an ar game
and was the easiest way to explain it
but there is another game called ingress
that actually came out before pokemon go
similar to pokemon go users are expected
to walk around the real world and visit
nearby landmarks and parks
but there is a little more involved with
ingress in fact
ingress players often joke about pokemon
go as being the kitty version of ingress
it doesn't have any of the cute little
creatures to capture and has a much
darker story behind it
of which i won't go into right now but
the players are to hack
portals and link them together in an
effort to conquer as much of the map as
you can for your faction
link three portals and everything in
between becomes your faction's turf
players are able to gain experience and
level up which opens access to more
powerful items that can be collected
the defense of these portals comes down
to the level of the gear and weapons
that's placed on them
and the more high-level players who've
placed gear on them the more difficult
it is to take them down
there is a real-time world map that
constantly updates the status of how
each faction is doing
and this can be narrowed down to country
or city
this led to very tight communities we're
in a number of instances that i can
recall
and this was a few years ago players or
agents as the golden game
would travel to different countries to
assist fellow members and regaining
control of the region
there are actually a surprising number
of events that are held all over the
world
i remember a friend of mine having a
plane ticket bought for her by her
faction
located in a couple of neighbouring
countries so that she could travel to a
remote island
and capture a portal that was under
enemy control all
so that they would stop linking to it
both ingress and pokemon go have certain
real world locations
that held significance within the game
gyms for pokemon
and portals for ingress these were all
based on real world landmarks that early
players of the game had submitted
and had approved i actually think i
still have a few out there and some of
them were
pretty ridiculous to be fair i think i
managed to get a park bench and a
rubbish bin accepted at one point
anyway what i'm trying to say is that
ingress already has the bones of what a
decent ar division game could be
the landmarks could represent well
landmarks
capturing these landmarks within a
certain area would gain control of the
region
for your faction the factions could be
shd versus rogues in the most simple
form but there's no reason why other
groups couldn't be included
think of a worldwide battle for control
there could be certain weapons and
skills that could be collected
that could be used in defending or
attacking enemy controlled landmarks
now i'm not just talking about this
because i think it would be cool and
that i was borderline obsessed with
ingress when it first came out
there have been a few little flags that
have had me thinking down this path
firstly several years ago in 2017
the ceo of ubisoft had a number of
interviews where he praised what niantic
and nintendo were able to achieve and
produce with pokemon go
he went on to talk about how ubisoft 2
is working on a product
using augmented reality but he didn't
really go into too much detail than that
however fast forward to just before the
release of the division 2
ubisoft released something called echo's
augmented reality experience
we call them echoes
echoes are all around you they recount
what happened near your grocery store
going somewhere no no no we're not no
we're not
your school one two
what's happening and even your local gas
station
be quick okay good it's working
discovering echo will unlock rewards
rewards that in a few weeks
will help ensure your survival
[Music]
in this short introduction to the game
users were able to explore around the
neighborhood
and find echoes these would provide a
small amount of story towards the main
game
that will be coming out in a few weeks
but also some in-game cosmetics
this app or game had very little content
and didn't take long to acquire all
available collectibles
but it didn't really feel like it was
just a marketing piece for the division
two
it wasn't even available in all
countries it felt like more of a test of
some of their basic framework
to be utilized more in depth later on
like they were just toying with the idea
at that stage
perhaps for a future mobile game they
had in mind
[Music]
so what do you think the division
augmented reality would certainly bring
a different type of gamer
while still being interesting to a
number of us who enjoy the main game
i know i could certainly use a reason to
get off my ass for a change and get some
exercise
but truth be told i actually hope it
doesn't go down this path
if it's anything like ingress i'll
probably end up being obsessively
competitive again
and i certainly wouldn't have the time
to be making content for youtube anymore
or spending time with my family or
turning up to work
or eating but my region would definitely
be well defended
regardless we'll hopefully be finding
out more about their plans for the
division and the various games they're
working on for the franchise at ubisoft
forward or e3
in june thank you very much for
listening to yet another edition of
ngn attempting to create gaming ideas
for the division franchise
catch you in the next one cheers
[Music]
foreign